[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Johnny is
with us in Irvin California hi Johnny
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi there thank you for taking my
call how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up great well I'm calling
to see what you guys would do if you
were in my shoes I'm 22 years old I
fully support myself I take home about
$5,000 per month I have zero debt I have
$60,000 in savings a $3,000 emergency
fund and I've been listening for the
past year or so and some of my friends
and mentors are into long-term real
estate investing so I've been saving
towards that for the past couple of
years ideally I'd like to start building
some long-term wealth wealth and so I
just wanted to see what you guys would
do if you were in my shoes wow you are
beyond beyond ahead of the game well
done very well done thank you well I um
probably have a different view on real
estate investing than your
mentors sure and I probably own more
than they
do given that I own about 600 million
worth okay um but anyway the uh uh I I
do not believe in borrowing money Johnny
because you and you've heard that
listening to the show and I don't for my
real estate investing I pay cash for it
and so the first real estate investing I
did and I've always loved real estate um
that I did after going broke and
starting completely over and with this
new I don't borrow money thing uh as a
part of the guidelines uh was I didn't
do real estate investing at first I just
started piling money in mutual funds and
when I got enough in in an in in an
index fund is what I used an S&P 500
Index Fund when I it took me about five
years to buy my first incom producing
property I paid cash for it and then I
took all of those
rents net of expenses and any other
money I could could and I threw it in an
index fund until I had enough to buy
another property and then I took all the
rents from the two properties and any
money I could scrape together from
anywhere else book royalties or whatever
else and I bought another property for
cash and every time I bought another
property for cash I had more cash flow
to buy another property
faster than I did the one before does
that make any sense yeah that that makes
perfect sense that is a very long-term
play versus what you have been
considering until this phone call
sure because you're thinking about
getting up a down payment and going
buying a nice little duplex in
California exactly yeah and I'm telling
you to wait and pay cash for it which
your friends aren't going to like and I
don't really care they're wrong that's
true but you called knowing you were
going to get a different take which
tells me you're actually interested in
this
take I am yeah i' I've just been curious
what to do because I feel like I've I've
been saving decently and I'd like to
continue that um but you know once you
get a certain amount of money I feel
like it burns a little bit of a hole in
your pocket you're ready to jump into it
yeah and you've done really well Johnny
I mean let's face it you're 22 years old
you have 60,000 bucks in the in the bank
and no debt at all and you're making 5K
a month you're killing it dang dang very
impressive and it doesn't sound like you
lead a super luxurious lifestyle you're
a
saver I I try to be for sure there's
there's a balance so the key is to keep
living on less than you make what would
be interesting if you want to be really
nerdy I don't know how nerdy you are I'm
real nerdy is and I've done this a
couple of times it's and it it always it
always works that's why I'm putting you
up to it is if you say all right when
I'm
42 would I rather own $10 million worth
of real estate with $8 million worth of
debt or would I rather own $3 million
worth of paid for Real
Estate yeah I think the clear answer is
the 3 million yeah and then here's
what's here's the here's the exercise
run out the the purchase snowball which
is not a debt snowball but the way I
talked about a while ago rents buy more
buy more buy more buy more everything's
folded back into the next deal and the
slower start ends up with a faster
end the faster start ends up with a
slower
end my way is slower start but has a big
time payoff at the end because hockey
sticks from an exponential mathematical
equation perspective does any of that
make
sense yeah definitely it does cuz when
you get all this property that's sitting
there paid for you are buying more
property faster than you would have if
you had a whole bunch of property that's
not even close to paid for and it's not
cash flowing nearly as
generously so the math says I can buy I
can buy more property faster now it's
ridiculous what my real estate fund now
looks like from my real estate
income you now CU I'm at the back of the
story right so but I can't get people to
to think long term and I might have just
got one 22y old to do it though who
knows I'm impressed he sounded
interested yeah we can just get off Tik
Tok we'll get there